It will be remembered as the age of
revolution of the information technology
revolution,
which is only comparable to the
industrial revolution,
which changed the nature of the globe,
not just America,
but worldwide,
instantaneous communication,
flow of information and knowledge,
and an incredible fashion.
And the impact that all of this
information and flow of information and
ideas is having on the world is not
really for us to,
uh,
that I can accurately predict to you,
except you're going to have better
informed world,
a better educated world,
a cleaner,
a better world as far as the spread of
democracy and freedom is concerned.
And,
uh,
you're going to have a world that,
um,
is,
who's economy is basically global in
nature.